thank you
life is yours but you can change it
my people perish because they lack
knowledge they lack information
[Music]
left
the church premises are vasts they
include two Banks here there's a
shopping mall and a fuel station under
construction there's also a hotel that
houses the sick police say they're
investigating cases of people who've
died in here whose bodies they say may
be among those buried in shakahola
forest
[Music]
thank you
how do we protect our country
from unnecessary Safari
which is brought by people who are
misusing the freedom of
worship that is guaranteed in the
Constitution
foreign
thank you